皆さん最近のニュース
見ましたでしょうか？
Twitterとかでもニュースになってたと思うんですけど
トカゲって打つと
候補で静岡って出てきます
凄い産経ニュースとかYahoo!ニュースにもなってる
えー、ニュースです
静岡市葵区瀬名川の住宅街に大きな・・・
はぁ・・・（くしゃみ出そう）
！！くしゃみ！！
ヤバ
警察の方が捕獲に失敗した様なので
オレが捕まえるしかないやろと！
オレ達が静岡の平和を守るしかないやろ と
いうことで
ほ、報酬・・・賞金とか出ないんかな
だからもぅ、嫌じゃん
歩いててさ もし１メートルのトカゲが飛び出して来たら
嫌でしょ
とりあえず地域にその様な怪獣が
出ってるって事は
我々が何とかするしかない
と ゆーことで
何とかして
トカゲを 探して 捕まえて
静岡の平和を守っていきたいと思います
では行こう
はじめ：ヤンキーじゃんｗ
後輩：いやいやいやｗｗ
後輩：ここが瀬名川の田んぼなんすよ
はじめ：ココか
後輩：とりあえず聞き込みとかしますか？
はじめ：歩いてる人が居たら聞いてみよう
後輩：すみませ～ん
後輩：あのぉ
後輩：この辺でトカゲ・・・
はじめ：ナンパじゃんもうｗｗｗ
女性市民：あ～ 見てないですね～
はじめ：どこらへんで見たとか分かりますか
女性市民：ちょっとわからない ですね～
なんだそれぇ～
はじめ・後輩：ｗｗｗ
はじめ：一瞬で心読み解いて
すげぇナンパ技術かと思った
後輩：ふふっ（小声）
いるかいなんかで 言うと　-いないね-
後輩：あ！！
はじめ：え！？
後輩：知ってそう 知ってそう
はじめ：行こ行こ行こ
はじめ：どんどん行こ
はじめ：すみませーん ここら辺で
トカゲが出たって話を聞いたんですけど
どこらへんで出たとかって 知りませんかね？
はじめ：（何言ってんだろ聞きとれん）
はじめ：はい
あー、バイパスの方ですか
はじめ：なるほど
後輩：たいぶ僕の予想と場所が違った
はじめ：場所は確定した
はじめ：もうちょい奥かな
2人：あ！？え！？
はじめ：今見た？今見た？
後輩：通ってみます？
はじめ：通ろ通ろ
めちゃくちゃ人がいました
はじめ：なに みんな探してるのかな
はじめ：トカゲかポケモンGOだ
はじめ：これは
完全に
バンギラスかトカゲだ
はじめ：あ、こんにちは～
はじめ：ト、トカ、トカゲですか？ｘ２
はじめ：お久しぶりです
トカゲですか？
はじめ：え！？見つかったんですか？
はじめ：あ～なるほどなるほど
はじめ：お疲れ様です（会釈）
はじめ：静岡の動物園の園長さんも来てました
取材陣スゴ！
はじめ：え、これみんな
みんな トカゲ、トカゲ勢なの？
はじめ：めっちゃ人いますよ
オオトカゲが居るであろう区域内に入っております
はじめ：痛い？ｗ痛い？ｗ
あ～///
はじめ：はっはっはっはｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ：お久しぶりです
はじめ：店長さん動画に映っても大丈夫ですか？
後輩たち：ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
以前、撮影でお世話になります
お世話になった動画はこの動画の概要欄にあります
チェックしてください
園長さん：水辺に現れる可能性もあります
園長さん：喉が乾くから
園長さん：日光浴をするために出てきて 体温を上げたりするので
はじめ達：あ～なるほど
園長さん：で、今ちょうど二時頃でしょ？
はじめ：見つけたら警察に・・・
園長さん：か、僕に捕まえるんで
はじめ：よろしくお願いします
はじめ：また遊びに行きます
トカゲって名前とかあったんですか？
はじめ：園長さんの話によると
はじめ：この日中二時くらいが
はじめ：ちょうど 日向ぼっこしに出てくるらしいので
こーゆー アスファルトの上でもで出来る可能性もあります
あと、飼い主の娘さんは視聴者さんでした。
はじめ：ほんとチャンスなんだろうね時間帯的に
後輩：たいぶチャンスっすね
はじめ：なるべくちょっと動いて探していきたいと思います
～BGM～
おばあちゃん：うちの孫があなたのこと大好きなのよ
はじめ：あ ほんとですか！
後輩：多分 今 トカゲか はじめか 地域で張り合ってる
こーゆーおしゃれな建物にトカゲは胸躍ってさ
はじめ：上でこーやってさｗｗ（ポージング）
はじめ達：あっはっは…ｗｗｗｗｗ
後輩：汚ねぇｗｗｗ
後輩：冷たいのが- ぺちょ-  って当たったｗｗｗ
あああああああああああ （後輩こける）
一同：ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ：ほら 魚いる スイミースイミー
園長さん：ぜんっぜん気配がないね 出てこない
園長さん：だけど この辺にいるのは間違いないと思う
はじめ：ほぉ～
はじめ：いないなぁ～
はじめ：んん～ いないなぁ
～また しばらく探してみる～
ザシュッ（刺さるSE）
はじめ：ああああああああああ
はじめ：スベンニャ～（ライオンキング風）
はじめ：ここが第一目撃情報でしたっけ
目撃情報があった場所らしいです
園長さん：向こう（画面奥）の方に歩いていったと
はじめ：ほぉ～
はじめ：いないっすね～ほんと
～悲しげなBGM～
はじめ：ちょっと見つからなかったので・・・
～ED（エンディング）～